spider warren going out there making his
spiderworm videos and he's got a he's
got a title here that just that just
sounded so interesting
spiderman no way home leak and weirdest
leak slash meme yet okay i want to know
what that means
don't want to do the exact melody
because
hey tell me more
[Music]
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
today we have a pretty interesting air
quotes here leak i've been covering
spider-man no way home since before we
even knew the title i've been covering
this for a very long time calling it
spider-man 3 back in the day and i've
never come across badass
underground
information about the movie now i do
have two leaks to talk about today the
first one bear with me it's really funny
and the second one is a pretty serious
one one pointing us in the direction
even more that toby mcguire and andrew
garfield will indeed be in spider-man no
way home which of course if you've been
following my channel i 100 believe they
are going to be in the film but i know
people like to get more confirmation so
this first part is just kind of
incredibly funny it's probably the most
clever marketing that i've seen and it
actually comes from domino's pizza their
official australian account now even if
this isn't legit it's certainly funny as
hectic pizza delivery
delivery
instagram page it's a job application
form and on it it says
from domino's
experience pizza delivery photography
applying for delivery expert and the
caption for the post reads received this
application yesterday but had to
reschedule the interview something about
a multiverse i don't know
now i don't know if this is just some
intern running the instagram and he
decided to post this i don't know if
it's something that they came up with
their own or if they actually have some
sort of a partnership with sony but
either way it's freaking clever and gold
i mean it's really well done if that's
coming from domino's they gotta be
working with them in some regard
especially because they got like the
spider webbing around it i i would kind
of get it if it was only like just the
text like with the toby m and the pizza
delivery there has to be something like
domino's who worked with them to use or
if they're just like
damn we got capitalists on the
spider-man run right now you know if
you're in australia let us know is
domino's doing some kind of promo but
that is a funny ass little thing to do
that is that is honestly hilarious and
it's funny how they actually and
specifically mention toby mcguire and
the multiverse especially peter parker
recently come out again this is
something that i just found really funny
i'm not sure domino's know something
that the whole entire world doesn't at
this point but really kudos to them this
is very clever now on to a more serious
matter there have been some photos of
toby maguire with tom holland and a
photo of andrew garcia what looks to be
in the same background circulating the
internet recently these are different
than the ones that i saw the other day
those are still on my twitter but the
background does appear to be the same
it's a blue screen a huge room covered
with a blue screen so we can look this
up yeah we would have to look at this it
apparently points to all three
spider-man being together with toby and
tom in one shot now there was talks
about whether or not this was fake and i
would post them on here but it looks
like they are real and they've been
getting taken down and accounts have
been suspended because they were posting
the pictures of course i really want to
show them to you but i can't have my
channel get taken away or any of my
twitter instagram being taken away
either but chris the editor still
decided to throw in blurry photos of
them and now we're at walkers now it's
in our video too chris
what do you think i get your plan buddy
you're trying to shut us down
shut down cause wonders so everyone just
goes to cosmic culture after that be
here to cut the crap bud where you get
off better cut the crap
but we will not be looking up those
photos i don't know on our own time
that's that's for sure we will not i
don't look or listen to anything leaked
all right
never ever
a court of law that is as long as the
words are said despite the tone we are
good that's right if you simply search
them online you can find them if they
haven't already been all taken down but
that is the main point here the main
point though yeah is that the fact that
they would take it down i mean that
they're actually real yeah yeah no
they're spending accounts
i probably unnecessarily interrupted the
video because he's probably gonna go
into that they are actually taking them
down if they were fake it wouldn't
matter they wouldn't be taking them down
but since they are it looks like they
are real this actually reminds me of a
time where i posted a plot leak for
wonder woman 1984 and warner brothers
copy strike me for it now luckily they
were cool and they dropped a strike but
when the movie came out it turns out
that the plot link was 100 accurate so
companies really only do this when the
leaked things are actually real maybe it
was dominoes
that's inside the pizza box lids and
spiderman no way home i know there's
still some doubters out there and i
totally get it you won't be convinced
until you see it on screen but at this
point there really is a lot pointing
towards this and again i've been told
that they're in the film by my sources
and unless a crazy amount of reliable
people in the industry are wrong they're
in it and we're in for a wild ride when
spider-man no way home comes out so drop
your thoughts about this in the comments
down below let me know what you think
about this domino's post because it
really really cracked me up don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell don't forget to like the video and
for a live update you can always follow
me on instagram and twitter as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof i mean with the domino's thing the
funny part about it is like that is the
kind of brand recognition that would
work on someone like me if there was
like some spider-man box even like some
spider-man pizza box i would need to get
one i would get one just to get the box
i am a sucker for things like that you
find me at a grocery store i see batman
at the very bottom corner of like a
frosted flakes box i'm going to go i
guess i got to buy this frosted flakes
now yeah you know yeah do that with gum
you're the guy who's gonna be at the
domino's like i don't even want the
pizza all right can i just buy five of
these yeah can i just get some boxes
please dominoes you better capitalize on
that because i already believe toby
mcguire and andrew garfield in here but
you guys have a gold mine here to unpack
guys subscribe to cosmic wonder if you
haven't done so already thanks for
putting this video together and
informing us about the great dominoes
subscribe to us hit that like button
first can't wait for the spider-man
movie last but not least whip
tongue punch fart box i think you would
have the greatest pizza delivery job in
the world i'm gonna give you three
seconds to think exactly where i'm going
with this joke three
two
one so tongue punch fart boxes a pizza
delivery boy would show up if they're on
an app it'd be like you're getting a
delivery from tongue pudge fart box and
then you show up to the door and they're
going to be like your real name tongue
punch fart box and you're like nah it's
it's just deontay but here you go and
then they smell that delicious cheese
and then they open up the pizza box and
then
and then punch in the face oh yeah this
just comes out and then you go you just
got fart boxed and then you run away and
you throw the pizza like down at their
feet
so they can't even eat the assault yeah
you'll be fired for doing that and you
probably won't work in the pizza
industry ever again be blacklisted on
the pizza delivery list on papa john's
list
oh papa john's blacklisting you then you
know things have gotten bad bad